four days after Hurricane Ian ripped
through southwestern Florida the
stranded are reaching safety
the roads to rebuilding are being
cleared survivors Are Thankful they can
see the sun once more
we shouldn't be alive right now with
that storm this is at the power of that
storm I mean if that would have crashed
into the side of the house we I mean it
would have we would have Swept Away
more than 800 000 homes and businesses
still have no electricity flooding
threatens communities struggling to
begin cleaning up and even in the face
of their own losses food banks try to
help others
we were able to start grilling and
cooking food outside yesterday we we
cooked for over 200 families that came
and just eating outside and yesterday I
only took water outside
today we took food because we were able
to kind of walk in here and get stuff
[Music]
the head of the US's emergency response
agency says even though Ian has passed
people still must be careful we see so
many more injuries and sometimes more
fatalities After the Storm because there
are so many dangers out there what I can
say is people need to stay vigilant
right now standing water brings with it
all kinds of Hazards it has debris it
could have power lines it can have
hazards in there that you just don't
know about and so we want to make sure
that people are being extra cautious and
as the death toll melts some are
accusing local officials of waiting too
long to give the order to evacuate dry
land bud
the official's response the government
can only do so much I also understand
that there are some people that don't
want to leave their homes we cannot
force them to leave their homes that's
their homes but we can do everything we
can to educate them and make sure
they're aware
of what's coming their way or possibly
because again this was so unpredictable
on this coming Wednesday U.S President
Joe Biden will tour the damage and meet
with residents and government leaders
his job reassure everyone the worst is
over Russell and Jordan Al Jazeera